rebel student leader and now a member of
parliament
this is Chile's Camila vehicle Camila
became active in student movements while
attending the University of Chile there
in 2010 the student Federation elected
her to be its president her leadership
was critical during the 2011
mobilizations when hundreds of thousands
of students throughout Sheila took to
the streets to demand Sheila is the most
expensive place to go to college in the
world when comparing costs to wages
after months of demonstrations and
repression to education ministers
resigned and Parliament made education a
top priority Camila was catapulted into
the limelight in 2013 at just 25 years
old she ran for Congress and guess what
she won and now continues to be a force
for change in Chile